[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos this is the
incredible Return of the incredible
David nickton who is a great teacher of
mine a great friend of mine a wonderful
Buddhist and a very wise and funny
person and I'm so glad you guys are here
to check him out if you want more Dave
and Nick turn after you listen to this
and chances are you might you very well
might go to dharmamoon.com that's his
organization
d-h-a-r-m-a-m-o-o-n.com dharmamoon.com
and you will see a link there for their
100 hour mindfulness meditation teacher
training with David nickton Val has done
it it's incredible he's incredible
you're about to hear hopefully you heard
the first chat if you didn't David and I
met at the ramdas retreat in Maui and we
had breakfast together and we ended up
talking so long we ended up having lunch
together at the same table because he's
just a wealth of information and just a
calming wonderful presence in my life
and I'm happy to share that with you
guys today not much to plug up top other
than dharmamoon.com I do want to say
I'll be on the road when this comes out
I'm I'm actually today heading to St
Louis so go to petehomes.com if you want
to see me in St Louis see you in St
Louis and then the weekend after that
I'll be in Salt Lake City there's more
dates being added uh if you just saw me
I'm doing a new hour I'm taking a new
hour out and I'm so thrilled with it and
it is so fun so I'll be adding even more
dates for the tour we're calling it the
feeling it tour this is the tail end of
the where where we tour for St Louis and
Salt Lake City but all those dates will
be at petehomes.com check it out hope to
see on the road always means a lot and
go to Largo
dashla.com for my monthly show in Los
Angeles the last one was so fun Kumail
was on it it was so cool check that out
it's once a month
largo-la.com there's definitely one in
October I'm just blanking it's on a
weekend I'm sure a weekend in October
largo-la.com and we're brought to you by
our friends today at on it Alpha Brain I
was just packing my bag to go on the
road Alpha Brain is such a huge huge
part of my life actually I did a show at
Dynasty typewriter last night and
someone had me autograph their Alpha
Brain bottle which I thought was
hilarious and wonderful and they knew I
would appreciate that I just packed up I
was putting my Alpha Brayden black label
in the bag it's a tight bag I travel
with one backpack not a lot of room in
there but I never never don't travel
pretty much anywhere without Alpha Brain
it's in my car it's in my travel bag
it's in the pockets of my jackets what
is it it's a newotropic what's that it's
Earth grown ingredients that help you
concentrate help you focus help you dial
in it helps your brain work it's not a
stimulant it's not like caffeine it
doesn't get you jittery it doesn't get
you why tired it gets you in that flow
if you need to concentrate if you need
to answer emails if you need to write a
script if you need to do stand up if you
need to do a podcast or if you just need
your brain functioning clearly and well
Alpha Brain 15 20 minutes before you do
that task makes a huge noticeable
difference it is a game changer in my
life I wish I knew about it in college
I'm so glad I know about it now give it
a try support your brain and you'll be
supporting this show go to on it
onnit.com weird you'll get 10 off
everything you see on that landing page
and those uh sales help support the show
helps keep the lights on here we
appreciate that it'll keep your lights
on keep your brain running smooth I take
it constantly before every show before I
sit down at my desk on it Alpha Brain on
it.com weird alright everybody hope to
see you in St Louis hope to see you in
Salt Lake City enjoy uh Dave and Nick
turn go to dharmamoon.com get meditation
mindfulness training from The Man He's
incredible get into it
can you hear me
Ken can you hear me yeah well seamless
yeah seemingly seamless
seemingly seamless same new loot what is
that yeah same seamless no it's not it's
s-e-a-m [__]
the second one steam yeah there's two
different things but they both have to
do with apparent reality
seems make it look like two things are
attached that aren't
so seams make it seem is what you're
saying as if it's seamless
oh
I'm so happy to see you sorry I didn't
want to interrupt I'm just this is the
welcome I'm just saying I'm so thrilled
yeah to have a little time with you it's
one of the great uh joys of my life that
this podcast provides these um excuses
to hang out you know what I'm saying
yeah and it didn't even exist like 10
years ago right
I know and I I think people would say
that oh that's when we were in coffee
shops and talking and I'm like I don't
think so I think we're talking more now
than ever I think all of these things
that are internet whatever supposedly
driving as a part are actually doing the
opposite I think I'm talking way more to
people than I ever have
well yeah and it's um
it's a a certain aspect of communication
is heightened by it don't you think
haven't you found that that's the whole
thing we're cooking over over a spit
right now the flame of urgency well you
know Val and I do the Friday episodes
and I'm like it's one of the keys to a
healthy relationship is is is having
nice long conversations once a week but
I would add to that if you record them
and you release them there's an urgency
so why do you go to a date why do you
wear a suit why do you go to a white
tablecloth restaurant it's to add a
little performance to it meaning it's
not just for show people Valentine's Day
is an open mic for regular folks you go
out and you do a song and dance look at
what we're wearing look at how we're
behaving how much are we laughing how
much are we touching all that sort of
stuff doesn't make it false or wrong but
human beings tend to do better when
other human beings are observing them
you know what I'm saying well and
there's also getting
rousing something yes which is um
probably the essence of decorum and
things like that where you create not a
superficial outer shell but a a kind of
level of expression that's related to
how others are connecting with you it's
not this kind of hyper casual and uh you
know uh clueless kind of vibe it's like
that's right the stage is set the table
is set and that's our whole look when I
was a kid I went through a real Holden
Caufield period where I was like oh
grown-ups are so phony and they talk you
know what I mean I I do hate when people
talk like they're on a conference call
even though they're not on a conference
call you know what I mean they're like
well that's great Jim like we're in line
at a coffee and they're like well yeah
let's Circle back to that and you know
let me jump off here I'm going to talk
I'm like why are you talking because
you've been so corporatized that you
can't even talk it's a person I hate
that so it can be perverted and taken to
an extreme right but there's something
fun it's a wedding it's a it's going to
a court to contest a ticket there's a
drama to it there's a judge there's
pillars there's marble even you know
firefighters and and and uh EMTs we we
created all of this meaning so we're not
just kind of like running around in the
woods and and there's a way to enjoy it
it's fun to be talking to you now as I I
don't five minutes ago I wasn't talking
at this register I'm turning it on baby
and it's fine turn it on
and this is exactly where I thought we'd
get to today which is
um the vertical and the horizontal
beautiful you and you Buddhist Master
just do it
and apparent reality
and the sort of more unconditional
quality of how things actually are so
it's how they are and how they appear
which is in every spiritual tradition
you'll find this um expressed some way
or another
um and the tension between those two
things
yes which means uh you go to church on
Sunday but on Monday you're actually uh
donating you know you're helping people
out in a Food Kitchen you're um you know
helping an old woman across the street
yeah and uh you know how
um
it's interesting in you know me I always
connected just because that's my
tradition to the Buddhist and
particularly Tibetan Buddhist
perspective is it's called Dune and
kunsap and dundum is absolute reality
unconditional just the way it is you
know you don't have to do anything it's
just it kind of intact and kunsap is
relative reality and it literally means
all dressed up it's just what you were
just talking about no way
all dressed up
whoa you you recognize that yes you do
put on the suit you do put on a tuxedo
to go to the Academy Awards or whatever
it is and you do uh put on a tie to meet
your girlfriend's parents uh even though
you you know that's not your style and
you do
um
you know
um set the table nicely for people to
come even though they're they're just
your friends they're the same idiots and
jerks who were having coffee with two
days ago but now we're putting out the
cutlery yes because
yeah yeah all dressed up and um but
recognizing that it's empty
so the difference in the kind of in the
materialistic world you don't recognize
the emptiness of it right it just seems
like this is it this is what's important
this is the final answer and in the sort
of spiritual domain you don't really
give any Credence to the kind of uh
relative unfolding of reality and and
small relational things that happen
during a day right but in a in another
way you could integrate those two so
that you can get fully involved and
engaged in the play uh that you're in
but you you never have mistaken it for
any kind of absolute reality because
that would cause you I mean that would
make you pain it would make you paranoid
it would make you depressed jealous if
this is all there is yes jealous
bubbling with competition and jealousy
this is so great because I wanted to
talk about what you wanted to talk about
and I texted you and he said this is
what you wanted to talk about and this
is what I wanted to talk about because
if you remember like a week of course
you do a week or two ago I called you as
I do uh when I'm having a little crisis
I'm not having a crisis today I feel
fantastic today so I'm trying to honor
crisis Pete and remember him but crisis
Pete because it was serious right now
I'm like whistling I'm just like what
was that all about but there are people
listening that are that may be feeling
this which is I was starting to panic I
was getting a little too close to what I
would consider Ultimate Reality meaning
you even hear this in the Christian
tradition I was getting it from A Course
in Miracles but I'm also reading James
Finley's book and he talks about how God
Alone is real like everything else is
sort of like a play or a dance it
doesn't have to be nefarious but it's
not real it's it's and you can even look
at it scientifically you could go it's
all molecules it's all atoms you can do
it from wherever you want to stand and
you go like but it seems like it's a
shirt you know and I was starting to
panic because I was like what about I I
was getting too much of
well the way it was manifesting and we
can get to this in a moment but I'll
load it into you as I was like if God
Alone is real and god is perfect Oneness
God doesn't even know about this world
which in in the way that we think of
knowing you know what I mean like
subject object God is over here in
heaven and he's watching me and David
have a conversation that's not perfect
Oneness that's Tunis that's God over
here watching David and Pete so that
it's actually voyeurism is what it
really is it's disgusting boy or yeah
yeah we've made this observation before
that that's kind of freaky I mean yeah I
just took a shower
the fact that nobody's watching
right is that how you feel do you feel
no one's watching no but nobody's
watching that's great that's what I was
going to ask you so but that that can
freak you out so let's unpack that I
want you to unpack it when you get into
vedanta when you get into non-dualism in
any it doesn't have to be vedantic it
can be Christian non-dualism it can be
just private dude the more I look at
science uh I was just watching A Charlie
Kaufman movie you know and he's kind of
a famous nihilist and he was breaking
down how everything ultimately is one so
like you know physics religion we get to
this thing that it's all one thing and
if it's all one thing there's no no
there's no subject object and there's
nobody that knows about David please
unpack that and why aren't we freaking
out if that's the case
well
first of all
it's so sweet isn't it the whole thing
what a great place to start yes it is
there is a sweetness underlying the
whole thing that uh I think when we all
slow down enough to appreciate what's
really going on that there's an
underlying tenderheartedness to the
whole
even the even these kind of you know
heart-wrenching conversations you know I
agree I also thought you meant sweet
almost like a child you know kind of
wanting to understand why the sky is
blue and and grown-ups can get panicky
about why the sky is blue but there's a
there's a tenderness to just kind of an
innocent what's going on here is that
what you mean by sweet unpacked sweet
for me yeah a tender
um Nintendo soft-hearted you know not
not um defended not not um
uh
uh not frightened either
you know and um
you know so
you know like when we saw Mitch
McConnell freeze the other day did you
see that no
you didn't see that no I'm over here and
uh I'm playing with GI Joe's and [__] I
don't know well you know about that you
know uh oh Mrs Goldberg did you see what
happened over there in Afghanistan she
said I don't see nothing I live in the
back
no that's great you live in the back
yeah yeah well Mitch McConnell who maybe
somebody could have
vilified if they wanted to or needed to
uh as as somebody who represents a kind
of series of of um you know uh positions
and power that are contrary to what we
might think of as our healthy way to go
is standing at the lectern you know with
the and with the Republican guys you
know the whole thing and he he's zoned
out for a good 30 seconds oh wow he
literally went like this
oh wow
he froze in a Mind Freeze and on on CNN
wow on CNN or in well just the cameras
were rolling so they it's he there's no
way that somebody could you know and at
that moment he looked like and then he
came two and they were saying are you
okay Mitch and you want to go back to
your office or he had no idea what had
happened it was it was probably you know
like similar to fatimao you know a small
seizure or uh zoning out but he was
quite gone and you looked at the face
and you could see him as a little boy
you could see yeah uh and now obviously
you want to keep your aggression drummed
up and you want to stay angry uh but it
what I mean by the sweetness is you see
something like that even to somebody
that you may not be in Concord with at
the moment and you feel sympathy I think
of trump sleeping all the time you know
what I mean the vulnerability of a
sleeping Donald like just and I'm not
trying to humiliate it I'm saying he's
drooling a little bit he's in some sort
of weird Twisted position he needs the
covers you know what I mean like there's
something helpful to me about thinking
about somebody that I may not agree with
on this that or the other pulling up the
sheets in their sleep like their body
was old and I can't I can't really
handle it I can't handle the tenderness
and the vulnerability the dandelion-like
quality of all of us and a lot of these
dandelions put on suits and they we comb
our hair in a certain way and we yell
real loud and I'm like I do the same
thing with bodybuilders Dave Batista put
him in the ocean put them in the ocean
like these big [__] guys put them in
something bigger than him and instantly
where's where's your power it's gone and
and that I don't do it to humiliate them
I do it to go so stop it's real it's
real it's relational my thinking Dave is
big is because I'm not a mountain and my
thinking Trump is whatever blowhard
let's say is because I'm forgetting that
he's a he's a baby he's a he's a
dandelion like like me and like all of
us so the sleep thing helps the the like
or or eating eating a bowl of soup alone
in a mall well you know this is a very
profound issue for us now because
uh you know like to
um
Friday night I have to teach a workshop
in Japan on the path of the warrior so
this notion of warriorship is a very
powerful idea but the two elements to
the more
nuanced version of warriorship is
gentleness and fearlessness it's not
just fearlessness it's gentleness and
fearless so it has a sort of a mother
father energy to it so the question is
is how can you
um
you know act in a world in a way that is
um and we we're gonna it's funny I'm
teaching in Japan but we're going to
talk about Bushido you know because they
already have the code over there
they have the source code it's if you
just look at Bushido and and what it's
advocating in a samurai it's the sense
of um uh compassion is one of the things
virtue developing virtue
um you know um Integrity all the things
that if you could get people to
um tell you what was important to them
the list would be fair unfort would be
very similar I think for a lot of people
don't you think that if you idealized it
you know well I love even you just
reminding me of those words taking us
back to the horizontal and and the
vertical right is I do catch myself
and as you were saying that I was like
right I'm a father I want to model these
things for Leela right I lose them all
the time Nikki this going back to what
you were saying no one's watching
um and I've had spiritual experiences
you know some on drugs some not on drugs
where I've really experienced like the
Oneness and the all okayness and so
there is it's not coming from a place of
Terror but sometimes I go there's almost
like a
I lose touch with what you just said
like the idea of integrity and courage
and all that stuff because I'm kind of
like I don't know man who cares and it's
it's sort of a dangerous and soft place
for me because then I start to retreat
from
from life because I'm like it doesn't
matter and that's not the sweet spot for
me I I was very excited to tell you that
I did a show last night and I hadn't
done a show in a while it was all new
material and it was like getting a blood
transfusion today I'm I'm myself I'm not
afraid I'm connected I feel part of
something you know the audience and me
merged and it was it was absolutely
life-giving anxiety and fear reducing
and today the world is beautiful and I
couldn't just conceptualize my way there
you know I couldn't just go like I'm one
with God so everything's okay I had to
do stand-up comedy what does that make
you think of
um it makes me think of a baby and a
nipple is what it made me think of
it just speak spontaneously yeah sure
getting what I need
yeah and the you know I'm doing what's
natural too it's natural
and having the exchange with with
um so here's the thing the vertical
if misunderstood can become nihilism
yes you feel Eternal non-dual there's
you know it's there's no point in
engaging the horizontal there's no point
in going doing stand-up comedy there's
no point in uh having children and the
the
Eternal that you know kind of
sensibility
pulls you back from engagement at a
relational level can I just interject
and say the vertical we've been talking
about it we mean like kind of divine God
higher truth ultimate truth horizontal
being your life your your day-to-day
yeah just in case people didn't know yes
and vertical also means Timeless yeah
because in embedded in in US is the
experience of timelessness whether we
have acknowledged it or not everybody
it's it's like a little tickle in every
back of everybody's mind oh this is
timeless this is this is and ironically
and this is you know congratulations
whoever
uh it formulated this the Timeless is
related to extreme loudness
that's the only access that we have to
it any other version of it is a fiction
right
Mitch Mitch McConnell
well those who see that was what was
also interesting about it you see these
great yogis you know these and they're
in a similar as mentioned
well it's it's like but it's it's
suffused with awareness it's different
but nothing is happening
yeah there's no fear that nothing is
going on there's no need to speak
there's no need to do anything but the
the quality of its awareness whereas the
quality with um with absorption States
you know whether physical or drugs or
whatever is that there's opaqueness and
the lack of awareness
so that's a very important distinction
because as people practice spiritual
traditions and they access certain
states of mind the question is do they
become absorbed into them and kind of
addicted to it almost you could say or
or can they let it come and go uh and
recognize this sort of fundamental
quality of timelessness in it that it
doesn't need to be sustained in any way
right right it doesn't need you to to
attach to it or try to sustain it in any
way it is actually the ground of being
right you're for you're thinking you're
leaving this place where God isn't to a
place where God Is by taking Ayahuasca
or something and then you come back to
the waiting room and it seems to me that
spirituality is going like well this is
I believe it's a Psalm it's like I make
my bed in the depths you are there I go
to the heavens you are there all of
these Traditions seem to have this idea
of like where could you go that isn't
saturated in the ground of being which
is you know the mystery we call God or
isn't this or or awareness or whatever
you want to call it yeah and ironically
you can bias the person's
accessing it in in uh in the time in the
contract Buddhist tradition they call it
ordinary mind
is that cool yeah ordinary mind so you
don't look for it in the extraordinary
uh uh there's nothing about it that like
like we were with a group of people
meditating last night out here and I
heard this woman give this rap and it's
like oh there's planets and you could
send your thoughts out and projected you
know and then you know there was a
little dog uh behind her going like that
while she was doing that and that's the
ordinary mind more than the projection
out of your Consciousness out into out
into the Universe I agree isn't that a
temptation as well I mean I I have
friends and I love these friends I
wouldn't change them for the world but
they we want to talk about UFOs and
other life forms and other planets and
everything and I'm sort of like
it's not ordinary mind is what you're
saying and and the people that I love
are like stones they're here they're
they're they're finding it
on the plate they were served instead of
looking over across the street at the
restaurant where they like are cooking
at the table like a Benihana like
something exciting right
yeah yeah Benihana nothing's more
exciting than a Benihana yeah am I right
about that well nuts yeah and and that's
where the all dressed up the kuns up
thing becomes uh an obsessive costume
party with disguises rather than
ornamentation you know you're looking to
disguise yourself you're not comfortable
being seen as yes as you are rather than
rather than your regalia is some kind of
ornamentation and elaboration of your
basic good quality you know it's a
hiding hiding out so how you know a lot
of people were hiding out you know what
I mean we're not really willing to show
up um very simply and very plainly
because it's too painful Maybe
embarrassing is my favorite word these
days all right well you've just walked
into a very warm space because Val and I
in uncovering the phrase I'm sorry I was
embarrassed is the most valuable phrase
I think I've learned as a as a grown
person like that's the wisdom of my 40s
is you start overreacting and you just
go I'm sorry I was embarrassed like you
were embarrassed you didn't know
something you did something you looked
weird you're back in junior high for
just a second you're in your body it's
pooping it's farting it's burping it's
it's scared it has all these
psychological needs these physical needs
these respect needs it's so it's
embarrassing and and it's hard to deal
with is that what you mean that is
exactly what I mean and it I'm you know
I'm not surprised you stumble on that
word but I think if if people lined up
their biggest fears you know and said
if you just look day to day
embarrassment is way up there yeah I
agree you know and if you're running a
company or like you know uh think about
you know working with people like you do
and stuff if you embarrass somebody uh
you've put them in a really bad place oh
yeah oh yeah they're gonna really create
uh any kind of CounterPoint to to to
alleviate that
and and you know it sounds like so
dramatic but it's like the emperor has
no clothes it's that it's that premise
you know in what people know that well I
know that story The Emperor is naked and
and nobody wants to tell him it's
actually an incredibly powerful metaphor
it comes up a lot in show business
especially Emperor's naked nobody will
say anything until a child finally
points out the emperor has no clue well
because everybody else is in on the con
right they're on the page they have skin
in the game you know okay I'm the Duke
so I can't tell the guy
he'll defend himself and he'll undoukify
me you know that's what the kid doesn't
know so the kid goes he's not wearing
anything and then everybody goes like
right you know uh so who is that kid
that kid is kind of
you know innocence or pure uh perception
or just um you know it's not it's
Consciousness without an elaboration of
a need to create a self and an identity
and defend the crap out of that and yeah
um you know manipulated and con it and
seducing attack it you know so that the
kid oh sorry go ahead I'm tying it back
to the embarrassment the kid has to come
in and say you were just embarrassed now
the kid isn't embarrassed but everybody
else realizes that the reason they
didn't tell the truth is they were too
embarrassed yeah or they had too much
skin in the game
that's probably something else we should
consider too right along with the
embarrassment oh for sure you'll never
see people more full of [__] than once
money and power and Status gets involved
like I I've said this before but when
you're in certain powerful circles
you'll notice everyone's laughing in the
same Cadence as the boss
and you're just like that's the emperor
has no clothes that's like once you
start feeding somebody and giving health
insurance to their children you can
pretty much say goodbye to honest uh
Discord
if I'm feeding you and paying your
wife's medical bills you're not gonna
tell me as clearly or as plainly that
this sucks or that sucks and you see
this I love movies about corporations I
keep pushing the movie Blackberry it's
about the Blackberry phones and of
course there's a guy trying to tell the
other guy who's Drunk on Power that he's
cruising towards a wall and no one wants
to tell them because they're they all
have stock and they all are making
millions of dollars but there's always
one child saying the emperor has no
clothes it's very valuable
yeah
it's profound in a way because if you're
trying to build like for example both
you and I are actively engaged in the
world you have your your
um a fully
launched in our career presenting your
creativity to to to larger and larger
groups of people I've I'm developing
this company Dharma Moon we have 20
employees we we're trying to introduce
meditation practices to people in a way
that's accessible and but also authentic
you know which is kind of a hard that's
a hard enough combination to put
together
um like you know it's not really uh
great marketing to say well you might
get bored and frustrated when you
meditate because everybody has else is
painting a Rosy picture of it and also
by the way you know this whole rigmarole
you have going on it's gonna like Decay
and die you're gonna die you know so
those and that's the Buddhist um the
best the Buddhists can do for the
marketing is is borders well this is why
this is why Christianity from a
marketing standpoint I mean
fundamentalist Christianity yeah not
what I would consider authentic
Christianity but like they have a much
better sales pitch you're gonna die
you're going to go one place or the
other so you better believe now that's
literally how I would sell you an iPhone
you know what I mean it's the same
strategy that I would sell you a car
you're you're gonna die you should live
you should you should enjoy you know
what I mean and you're over there going
you're gonna die it doesn't matter this
is going to be boring and hard that's
that's a much more difficult sell but
they don't want to tell you about the
Dark Night of the soul that all the
saints went through including of course
including including Jesus Christ didn't
he have a dark night of the Soul oh yeah
the whole thing take this cup from a
mouth yeah so the fact that there might
be
um you know
um
a journey implied that is not going to
be in alignment with your wishful
thinking that's I mean absolutely that's
underreported and I think it would make
Christianity so much sexier I'm always
trying to remind people or more exciting
is what I mean meaning baptism as I've
said a million times is a drowning
ritual it's killing it's murdering you
and and you come back as something else
you've died and the Saint John of the
Cross and others that talk about their
Dark Knights of the Soul they talk about
like a peak that they have to go to and
let's say the peak is Enlightenment or
self-realization or conversion is what
Christian would call it
um you have to go and even Jesus doesn't
go with you it's like Thomas Merton
talks about when you die you're alone
you might be in a bed you could even
pull all your loved ones up onto the bed
with you if you die alone and he goes
the Paradox is the way away from that
Terror isn't to deny the solitude it's
to drink deeply of that Solitude embrace
it and and explore it and discover that
what you consider aloneness is actually
infinite Oneness it's the uh you're good
and I've had death experiences again
some of them have been on drugs some of
them are not but you go
you go home like going home is such a
such a weak way of saying it it really
is like you're discovering that what you
thought was Zero was the whole thing
does that make sense yes and the
aloneness Really rings out and I I think
that's something for people to wrap
their minds around we're not talking
again not talking about nihilism
yes which is oh I'm alone it doesn't
matter even if I fell in love we're both
gonna die it's not that and the opposite
extreme is eternalism which is that you
know we'll all be protected we'll all be
safe we're you know there's something in
between in which um
uh nobody can really uh
go there with you actually that's right
but
why that's not dark because here I am
you're saying that and it's delighting
me when as you as Merton says when you
drink deeply of what you perceive as a
separate individual you perceive it as
nothingness when you go into that
through meditation through quiet uh
whatever it might be obviously Merton
was a was a cloistered monk he was doing
a lot of Silence work when you get
comfortable enough and trustful enough
and and brave enough too to go what is
this thing inside me that when I'm not
thinking or doing that is that I'm
afraid of uh when I go into it you re
it's the prodigal son you realize
actually you've just come home and your
father throws a party for you of course
that that that that sounds silly but
it's just a way of kind of tasting a
little bit that the nothing is
trustworthy is that would you agree that
nothing is trustworthy
uh yes in a sense I would agree and in
another sense I would say who's doing
the trusting is what the very issue is
that and that's why I said there's
nobody watching that's I'm not a
nihilistic statement
um like and there are exercises that you
can do you know in any kind of training
um of looking like let's take just a
meditation tradition the Buddhist
tradition first thing you do is look at
this heavy fog of thoughts that you have
that has become your reality you're in a
movie basically and it's just scene
after scene I've seen inside your mind
right and you start noticing that moving
because you're now not participating in
that you're just watching it so they
call that the witness or the abstract
watch or something like that you begin
to notice your own mind for the first
time as having this kind of um narrative
to it this this this thing
I was going to say you're knowingly uh
unconscious you're watching you're
watching the stream of of of not really
wakeful thoughts and and emotions
parading by as it does but without
engaging it so that's a very different
thing you're developing a different
relationship to sing it now what is it
that's seeing that is another point
right what who is that a scene without
being involved in it without engaging it
and we you might call it the witness
Consciousness or the abstract Watcher
there's different names for it it's a
it's a kind of still awareness with a
sense of self attached to it it's
subtler it's like a subtler p a smarter
p a more aware Pete is watching gross
Pete out in the world going blah blah
blah blah now in other practices you
start looking at subtle Pete
and you go okay what is subtle Pete made
of just like you looked at gross Pete is
made of all these kind of Habitual
patterns and stories right now subtle
Pete is more like pure awareness but
still has some kind of perspective of
existence that you think yeah on subtle
Pete I've I'm I'm conscious I'm awake I
see it but when you look directly at
that that's kind of um
mahamudra style of meditation you look
directly at that and see if there's
anything there to identify hmm look at
subtle Pete
is there when you look at subtle David
is it something it it can
you can look there's two ways you do it
experientially and you just kind of go
okay let me just feel my way to settle
you get the difference between gross
feed and subtle Pete right I do yep okay
so subtle Pete could feel like I'm I'm
progressing on my path I'm seeing my
habitual patterns I'm much less reactive
than I was
um I'm still caught up with this that
and the other thing but I have a vantage
point it's like the referee in the
tennis match you're sitting higher and
you're seeing the play of the game now
when you direct whatever lens there is
directly towards that experience of the
of the witness The Observer
um you either will come up with
possible explanations for what that is
oh that's pure awareness that's God
that's you know whatever you come up
with
um or you begin to find that you can't
find it
so the Buddhist approach is in not
finding there's a lot of power that's
why it goes in through that form it's
emptiness kind of realm in not finding
something that's a legitimate experience
it's not finding something you expected
to be there
binding is not finding
well if you can't find the thing uh that
that that can be a very productive thing
to do is to not find something
we normally think I got to find this I
got to find subtle Pete I got to Define
it I got to get words for it I gotta
form a club around it I gotta
um you know build rituals to recognize
it but but if you really look directly
at it it's usually the case over the
centuries that it's hard to it's hard it
gets more and more ephemeral and Elusive
uh and dissolves
it's funny the Traditions that I study
more often would say ineffable or you
know words fail it and it's it's it's a
it's an experience that you can't
describe but you're saying it's because
it's not really it's would you say it's
not there it's funny this is that
Buddhist thing where the razor is just a
little bit sharper and it Shades just a
little bit closer because there's a
comfort in going like it's so beautiful
I couldn't describe it but that still
implies that it was there you're saying
actually the zero of it the good healthy
right zero was its own answer is that
right
well yes and if you get to that point
you can rest in that that's part of that
instruction just rest in the zero in not
knowing in in in in the ineffableness
yeah rather than resting in the
description of it you rest in the actual
experience of it and so that's and
here's the irony
they say there's Bliss there
but the couple is bliss and emptiness
are coupled together Bliss and emptiness
now emptiness means you can't as you
said ineffable you can't really Define
it you can't really cling to it you
can't really bottle it you can't really
get back to it you can't really
cultivate it all those things would fail
so if in in dissolving that completely
you know literally P you know this but
there's practices that people do to this
day in caves and mountains called
rainbow body where they go into a cave a
yogi goes into a cave and practices and
the whole body dissolves and only the
hair and the nails are left on the floor
of the cave after two weeks I've heard
stories of that I've rainbow I've never
heard it called rainbow body rainbow
body because everything the material the
gross matter dissolves basically they
dissolve themselves it's essentially
into light
and through meditation I suppose it was
very specific set of practices now
that's like people shouldn't get too
crazy about it it's very advanced
practice and it counter-indicates
a bodhisattva intention of like I I'm
gonna keep working with the gross
material I'm going to work with other
people I'm going to help I'm going to
clean the toilets I'm going to do
whatever I have to do to be a good a
good servant for others so but that's
interesting yeah go ahead so but the
asset the essence of our being
that's what I'm saying is if you look
for that something solid that is our
being either the physical emotional or
even uh mental level it's very hard to
find
it's interesting I have two thoughts
about that one what you're saying if you
dissolve in the in a cave you're not
helping say me or you you know you're
not having this conversation that's for
sure right exactly but there's also part
of me that goes it's all one it's all uh
a dream is a is a nice way to put it or
Leela it's a dance it's a play
so would you talk a little bit about
like there is no such thing as private
salvation or private Enlightenment it's
like there's only one mind and if that
because there is there is such a thing
what do you mean as private you think so
well I mean I'm again I'm sort of
chronically Buddhist in my perspective
but it's called the hiniano the narrow
glitch yeah I mean the narrow vehicle is
yeah you individual salvation it's
called so-so tarpa in tibetan individual
Liberation and you are free from the
wheel you're not being reborn in those
six Realms of like you know pleasure
seeking or fear but isn't there part of
you that thinks that that was just
written so that your one mind the one
mind that you and I share that were
aspects of is just kind of booby
trapping itself to trip and when you
David wake up you will go ah that was
just a that was just a way that David
could understand that he made Buddha he
made uh your Guru he made all these
teachers and they seem to have private
Enlightenment to show me that I could do
it but in the end it was just me it was
your dream it was one dream
in the Buddha's Sangha there are people
called arhats and they were people who
had achieved this and they went to sit
in a different section of the they went
to the loge you know oh VIP lounge yeah
the VIP Lodge but then there were the
bodhisattvas which was another another
level of accomplishment because those
were people who had taken on a bigger
Vision about what's possible
and then there's the Buddhas who
probably are closer to what you're
talking about
my best estimate would be a Buddha is
not no longer vetting these distinctions
there's no need
The Compassion is the same as the
emptiness
The Emptiness is the same as the form
the Oneness is the same as the
multiplicity yeah and and there's
spontaneous existence which is kind of
not calibrated the way what we do every
day talk about this
[Laughter]
talk about this because you and I are
presupposing time and and oh David will
wake up here and the Buddha woke up then
and Jesus woke up here whatever it is
but when I was telling you about time
yeah either eternity is true or time is
true and it seems to me that eternity is
true uh and talk about the the idea that
it's all happening at once and it's all
already happened and the relief of that
or so in any system that has evolved
over time for working with people
there's a gradual sort of sense of
training right and then there's a kind
of quicker sense of training and then
there's you could say more advanced kind
of training depends on the student
technically
so in terms of Buddhism the kind of a
more fruitional type of teachings Point
very directly towards the sudden quality
of enlightenment like Zen for example
they just pep you know and there's no
instruction there's no hey work with
compassion man work with your doctor's
Shadow it's just pep you know and and
you realize that someone blows out a
candle after reading the diamond Sutra
and that's when they become in line yeah
little I love those stories and the fact
is if you blow out a candle if you set
the right situation up with any human
being and blew out a candle in the right
way they would have a glimpse of some
kind of unfabricated uh experience
that they had not into or have lightning
that's a good one
have lightning yeah just a lightning
flash okay literal a real one people you
know Pete the joke is this is the joke
since you're a comedian you know the guy
who who um has one line in the play
you know I don't know the joke he has
you know his his line is they blow off a
cannon you know in the in the play and
he's supposed to say heart I hear the
Cannons Roar
that's this one like so of course he's
practicing at home with his wife and his
kids and he you know he's walking around
the house I hear the cat like say it
this way should I say it that way and
they every rehearsal of course they
don't fire up the real candidate the
rehearsal
and so
um at the rehearsal he goes hard I hear
the Cannons Roar and then even at the
dress rehearsal they don't want to race
waste the ammunition so it gets the
gestures now it's the actual opening
night and of course they blow off the
real Cannon he goes what the [__] was
that
this whole time I thought it was as a
comedian I'm trying to think of where it
might go that it's going to be like
cannons I hear the heart roar or
something like that so much better what
the [__] is that it's it's it's related
to what we're talking about if you
create a sudden shift
in the situation
are
continuous narrative will get broken
interrupted which is kind of Zen style
or sudden style you know you you they
say moo right there's another one you
know
um it's a Zen uh knock knock joke knock
knock who's there
interrupting cow
interrupting
how is that Zed that's my daughter's
favorite joke because then people say
moo
did you know that what do you mean
it's like it cuts through discursive
thought it's emptiness
right it's suddenly suddenly awake in
our tradition we call it suddenly free
from fixed mind
so you you everybody can have a moment
of like uh
in which there's no ineffable there's no
quality to it at all other than itself
and but it lasts for just a very short
period of time right
this episode is brought To Us by our
friends at ritual multivitamins they
also make my favorite Prebiotic
post-biotic and probiotic all-in-one
their symbiotic plus it's a huge part of
my gut health regimen it's also the only
multivitamin that I've ever taken and
seen real difference what does that mean
means they take it in the morning and
I'm ready to face my day it doesn't get
peed out everybody that I talk to about
multivitamin says the same thing doesn't
get absorbed you just pee it out turns
your pee into like Predator blood like
neon colors this one doesn't do that
because it waits until it's in your
lower intestine to break down so it can
be absorbed and into your body I was
always having vitamin deficiencies when
I went to the doctor ritual has taken a
huge crack at that and made a big big
difference in my life so you can talk
about fantasy football with your friends
all day but asking them for health
advice isn't really the move ritual
takes the guesswork out of the vitamin
game their multivitamin for men is based
on science to help fill common nutrient
gaps in the diet and level up your Nutri
goals it is an all-around win it's
scientifically developed with high
quality key ingredients in clean
bioavailable forms it's two it's your
new type of two a days for helping
support heart health with omega-3 DHA to
normal muscle function and normal immune
function with vitamin D3 this small step
can have a major impact that is
certainly true for me it is traceable it
is vegan friendly non-GMO sugar-free
gluten-free major allergen free doesn't
break a fast doesn't upset your stomach
if you're fasting which is huge for me
capsules delayed release as I mentioned
and even has a minty Essence in every
bottle to keep things fresh and help
make taking your multis every day
actually enjoyable and as I said I blend
it with their symbiotic Plus for my gut
health it's like a second brain you
gotta keep that micro
running smooth and get the fill those
gaps it's huge support your body support
this show I take it every single day you
guys should get into it well essential
for men is a quality multivitamin from a
company you can actually trust and get
this ritual is offering my listeners
thirty percent off thirty percent off
your first month visit ritual.com weird
to start ritual or add essential for men
to your subscription today that's
ritual.com
let's get back to David Nick turn
well it's interesting this is bringing
me back to last night Val and I again
I'm in my 40s valves in their 30s but
we're like realizing the importance of
disruption Val's always planning trips
and she knows she'll listen to this this
isn't [__] talk at meaning I'm the Grump
that's just a little bit less likely on
my week off to be like let's get on a
plane and go to the Ozarks you know what
I mean like it's just not it's not what
I would do but I am smart enough to know
that I'm wrong I'll give my and I and
I'm smart enough to trust Val and then
we go or a better example is we went on
a camping trip with our our daughter's
uh preschool class and you know you
sleep on the ground and the rational
mind says what are we doing sleeping on
the ground this is so stupid but then
you are happier you're lighter and then
and this isn't why you do it but then
the next time you sleep on your bed or
take a shower you're like this is
glorious all of these things came
through doing something that didn't make
any sense so I and and when I do stand
up it forces me into my body it forces
me into the moment and it's this Grand
disruption I don't know how it's going
to go especially doing new jokes feels
very new to me and that can snap me into
it is are we saying the same thing yeah
so you through your craft and you're
putting yourself in a situation where
you can be suddenly free from fixed mind
right that's part of the experience of
of uh you know being creative and being
you know and keeping keeping it fresh
and that's what a painter is doing and
that's what a basketball player is doing
that's what a rock climber is doing but
that and and absolutely and specifically
the kind of music you do that's
improvisational and flowing but it's
funny looking for things that the
listeners can get it's so easy to say
but it's it's hard to do like take a
different route home like walk the other
direction eat something you haven't
eaten watch something you haven't seen
even if you don't want to you have to
there's this like Stone mole inside of
the animal inside of all of us that just
wants its meals and its TV and it's bed
and it wants to you know orgasm
occasionally and it wants to be warm and
it's such a snooze but like it's so
seductive you know it's called it's
calling us towards the rocks and we
crash and we die you know sorry to force
this but like I do cold exposure I get
in 39 degree water every morning and and
one of the things one of the mantras
that carries me through is I go this is
life I say Heim this is life this is the
opposite of being in a nursing home I'm
coursing with [__] [__] yeah you know
what I mean it and it's and it's Warrior
energy you were talking about that
earlier it's a disruption and I know I
don't want to sound like an old man but
that is what in my 40s I figured out
that everything you want is on the other
side of something you don't want and and
and you should want what you don't want
you should want what you don't want is
is absolutely a key
wow
well
yes and that is folding this naturally
occurring event into the realm of
intentionality it's what you're really
talking about there you mean it's
happening anyway
yes yeah
and that is even creepier
tell me sorry keep going you go you go
you go you go well just that
we
what we take to be the floor of our
experience is a fake floor
it it's it's just by Nature there's
access to discontinuity what we're
really talking about is you would call
discontinuity we're used to making
things like okay I'm going from here to
there you're there and there's no Gap
right you know you're people talking
about a gap but the fact is the natural
mind has gaps in it and another way of
saying that to like Bright Young
people's our mind is actually digital
it's not analog
which is interesting in other words
there's about 128 frames a second of
mental activity
according to Buddhist ABI Dharma and so
each one is you're actually switching uh
like film you know appears to be
continuous but they're actually if you
could catch it there are gaps between
each moment of of apprehension
so we we don't tune into the Gap
equality of it
um like for example the next time you
walk into another room notice that you
might just have appeared in that second
room and you don't remember how you got
there
and you know as a lucid dreamer that
that's one of the ways you can tell if
you're dreaming lucidly or not is there
weird synchronicity man because I was
just thinking that I had coffee with my
buddy two days ago and I was like how
did I get here and I was like oh yeah I
parked over there and I went that's how
I know I'm not dreaming I just did this
because that's the key to learn to do it
in your dreams you do it in your Waking
Life you go how did I get to this oh
yeah Val went off to go upstairs and I
sent you the zoom link and you know I
have to that's how I know I'm not
dreaming yeah in a sleep dream but yes
that's what you meant yeah that there
the Gap quality is um part of the
activity of the mind and in meditation
you're just allowing your awareness to
experience that without trying to fill
it now normally the Gap is kind of um
uncomfortable from ego's point of view
so you're trying to fill it like oh I
think I'll flatter this person I'll
insult that person or I'll uh I'll I'll
take this uncomfortable feeling I
haven't tied it to a childhood memory
you're creating continuity of all kind
but the fact is frame frame frame
because you're in because you're
embarrassed and scared and it's too
wobbly
go yeah no because yeah that there's
some hesitation but the fact is it's
there anyhow which is sort of um of
course we we like to now I'm
understanding what you're saying it is
it's it's not it's seamless it's
seemingly seamless
interruptions woven together and built
in the same way that our minds take the
frame rate of television
we know if we slow it down it's it's not
what's happening but our brain fills in
all the gaps and it exists in our minds
in the same way reality is all of these
fragments woven together in our minds in
the same way that our eyes flip the
image upside down so we're not
disoriented the brain's job which makes
no sense it's one of the things science
doesn't understand why our world should
be upside down the way that the iris
works but it doesn't the brain corrects
it which is wild and the brain is also
stringing these frames together but the
Buddhist if I'm hearing you correctly is
trying to get a little bit more honest
about the frames and find the comfort
and the mystery and the Bliss in the
gaps am I forcing that well and the gaps
are are um
uh
uh natural and the only job you have
it's interesting because I as as
somebody who teaches meditation quite
frequently most people from where I sit
are working too hard at it to to map it
to their will you know to make it do
something that they want as opposed to a
sense of just adventure and exploration
and just let's see what's happening so
the only job in this kind of practice is
to notice
um the gap
that's it
notice nothing to do
yeah
and then that's the vertical
now if it loosens it up and if you
re-enter the horizontal you realize that
on a more relative level
we got way too serious about something
and what somebody said or you know it's
we made it too solid too thick and it's
gapless so you know the Gap is is a
natural event but it's also a way of
tuning in to openness and spaciousness
within the actual continuity that we're
experiencing you could just be
uh clueless for a second when you're
having a fight with somebody
normally we don't want to allow for any
confusion yeah or not finding it not
finding the next argument or the way to
win or the way to posture you kind of
want to have a conscious Mitch McConnell
moment
with awareness yeah that's what I mean
not a not a blankness but a knowing a
knowing pause
a vastness with awareness yes a spacious
thing yeah and it's just you know ah you
know just I mean it's in us it's part of
us we've gotten very
okay yeah
driven Muji who I love talks about he's
like don't try to open your heart or
close your heart he's like the heart
what we're talking about when you say
heart is an emotional state he goes the
real heart is always open and he goes
it's like space and he said this it
really moved me he goes this space that
we're in with the the room that we're in
with the table and the chair and you got
your walls and David and all that stuff
he goes this space a million years ago
was exactly the same and he goes fresh
and he goes and in a million years it'll
be the same fresh it's always fresh and
he goes you are that like stop thinking
you're an uptight person and now and now
you're a gracious person I'm very guilty
of that I listened to my thing I did my
practice and now I'm generous and he's
like that's not you the real you is like
the space in this room is always fresh I
loved the word fresh
like Trump yeah Fresh Start but then you
come to the kunzap part in in that way
of looking at it the relational part and
you it seems healthy and smart to also
work on that level
um gradual you know just sort of um
because it's very hard to pull that much
vastness and spaciousness down into
the relational world without giving the
so the relation the relative truth is
also considered truth it's not like the
absolute truth trumps the relative truth
the relative truth has its own wisdom in
its own sense of change and it reflects
the uh they reflect each other they
reflect each other that's what you told
me that calmed me down
I was like
uh I love my daughter and she's fleeting
and I'm fleeting it's all fleeting what
are we doing let's just get to God
already this it's almost like my
remnants of fundamentalism I'm like we
should just
strike the set burn it down it's over
this is over and you were like yeah and
also your daughters just hold like her
little hand is just holding my thumb
right now
and you're just like it's sort of wild
but one of the pitfalls of spirituality
is you can have those little existential
panics I have them to be honest I have a
good little Panic they don't even scare
me anymore I'm just sort of like oh it's
here I'm going like what is this and I
don't like I don't like asking what is
this what are you thinking
well you know
I I think to some extent
this is very much the transmission from
human being to human being
and I believe I believe in that so I'm a
lineage kind of person you know I I I'm
not thinking well the past was crap and
we should just just disband it so my
teacher trunk room says you know
said some very seminal things I just
wrote down Guru I was like I gotta ask
him about chunk bro yeah so it's um
uh he said to me at a certain moment in
time when I was having a kind of
stressful uh domestic situation he said
don't panic when things are going bad
and don't relax when they're going well
so I took that as what we call a pith
instruction I repeated it many times to
many friends and students
and it's a way to gauge okay you're in
that situation no matter what's
happening you think you're losing your
grip whatever don't panic
and then on the other hand when you
think I got this now don't don't uh
don't don't relax don't stabilize try to
stabilize that don't absolutely yeah
yeah so
um you know we these are called pith
instructions you know pith you know like
essential instructions and you know
ramdas had had one that I use right
which is which came from maharaji which
was um
love everybody and tell the truth
they sometimes have that quality of like
you could easily I could easily love
everybody man it's beautiful except you
know what and and ROM dogs had the
perfect student koan relationship the
truth is Maharaja I don't love everybody
right right oh
and the truth is that I would rather
things went smoothly and I'd rather
relax and not have to face the fear of
when things are not going well and and
freak out so they're Progressive your
ability to integrate a pith instruction
is Progressive it's very hard to just
and then you got it which is interesting
because that ramdas story sort of ends
with him realizing I I could be wrong
boy it would be fun to be able to talk
to him again but I'm sure he's I'm sure
he said it somewhere I'm not just saying
that as an optimist he recorded himself
talking a lot he was recorded a lot but
he sort of solved the love everybody and
tell the truth thing
I think by leaning into the Paradox of
It kind of letting it break his brain
like a Cohen
and going but then also when he
intellectualized it a little bit he was
like well I don't like David you know I
don't like a lot of people like a lot I
get overwhelmed a lot Often by people
who are like me if I meet someone who's
like me I get overwhelmed and I'm like
well get this [__] away from me like
real weird what a gift
what a gift
how's that
what could be easier than just you know
you're seeing something so clearly there
this person's like me and therefore
they're annoying me I mean that's like a
short that's a short ride on a short bus
[Laughter]
sure right on the short bus I
but when I go I don't like these people
but I know that's when I try and I don't
always succeed I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this it's kind of like the
Muji fresh space thing I try to go like
my father is challenging to me but I
know he's just in a costume he's just
he's he's he's he's the same thing as me
and he's wearing a disguise and I'm the
same thing as him and I'm wearing a
disguise it's it's helpful to me to
remember that Pete is a character in the
dream as well Pete is no more real than
my dad it's all sort of nonsense so hold
it a little bit more lightly and when I
think ramdas would say you know you
don't have to like everybody but when
you love who they really are that's how
you can love them and tell the truth go
this guy's annoying to me
so I heard a whole different thread when
you started talking about that yeah
here's what I heard you you know this is
just like
um I Heard
my father and I are actually quite
different
I'm not like my father and yet there's
this pressure
uh somewhat coming from him for me to be
like him because that means he's
succeeded in in crafting his own
Survival and Legacy yeah and this is uh
pressurizing for me personally so I have
to differentiate myself from my father
even though there are you know there's a
lot of things drawing us together
there's something pushing us apart and
that creates a certain kind of tension
in me about Paving my own Road
I don't know where that came from oh
that's that's right on that's absolutely
true the the painful thing I say about
my dad sometimes is I go he loves John
Mulaney I love John Mulaney everybody
loves John Mulaney but what does my dad
love about John Wayne my dad has never
seen John Mulaney tell a joke never seen
him tell a joke he likes his haircut and
he likes that he wears a suit so I find
that hurtful that I that sounds like
that sounds like Pee-wee Herman then
yeah what do you mean he could haircut
in a suit you kidding me he could love
that for sure but peewee's too silly bow
tie get at it no but the haircut in the
suit is what I was referring to of
course no I get it but but my dad
doesn't like Peewee he likes someone who
looks like a candidate
and the the thing that I find
challenging about that is you know my
dad would rather I look like I'm
together let's talk about John when he
was struggling like John is sober now he
would rather I look together and look
like a killer politician and have a
secret uh addiction problem then be what
I am which is kind of look like however
I look not not sharp not slick and uh be
embarrassing him with my you know
whatever my disclosures or whatever it
might be does that make sense like he'd
rather yeah and that means are very
different yeah you're not like that at
all no I'm the opposite of that
the opposite are different very
different yeah in other words you don't
care how people look you're you're a
feeling kind of person and you're
looking into their art and their
experience and so
um
yeah it's a funny thing because
the differentiation might um be part of
what we're all working with too is our
individuality
rather than having to move that to the
all one thing you know what I mean you
move it to the old one oh well it's just
we're all one and therefore my dad and I
are really the same and you know well
yeah how this is now the rubber is
meeting the road how then do I love my
dad if if my dad is bothering me and
challenging me how can I love him or
anybody and tell the truth what did you
take from that go on just the Paradox of
it or is there a way to do it
uh because I got pulled into the
particular experience that we're having
love him because he's different
yeah
is that possible
I'll tell you what happened I I don't I
don't do a lot of weed but when I'm with
my folks I just visited them when I saw
you I was about to go see them
and it was a challenging visit it was it
was it was hard for me and sometimes
after the visit I would take this little
micro dose of marijuana like 2.5
milligrams which anybody that does
marijuana that does marijuana is
laughing at how small that is it really
is a very tiny dose but when I would
take it
uh sometimes I I would be lying in bed
uh with Val or falling asleep and I
would start laughing
and should say what are you laughing at
and I go they're perfect I didn't mean I
liked them I go oh my God
they're perfect you couldn't I couldn't
script them in a million years what they
would say what they would do they are
one of a kind they are unbelie they
broke the mold like I'm not just saying
that this is not from a good Sun place
this is just honest journalism they
broke the mold I've never met a person
like them before or since and they are
unpredictable and absolutely
you know if you were looking under a
microscope at amoebas you'd be drawn to
them and go what the [__] is this one
doing so yeah and in that slightly
assisted place or you could say I don't
know if you want to say it's bringing me
up or bringing me down but it was
turning my brain off enough that I could
get to a place where I was loving them
almost like I wasn't myself like a
depersonalized experience well almost
like they weren't your parents
yes that too yep yeah I mean that's the
hardest one let's face it that's the
Home Run of Liberation your parents
I think so I mean that's a very big deep
and it's what's it's interesting that in
like in the monastic Traditions like in
Tibet they weren't raised that closely
with their family those those rimpitas
you know they were like chunk of
Adventure was taken away when he was two
years old and now the monastery his
teachers are really more like his
parents his mother's there they had the
mother thing and from that they got a
lot of compassion but I never heard him
talk about his dad
yeah can you imagine if you two two and
they took you to Comedy toku school and
you know yeah
the joke I was gonna make but out of
respect I I didn't want to was I was
like no wonder he drank which is which
is a joke but there's also got to be
people sometimes called trunk but
rinbache the drunken Buddha I'm sure
you've heard that before yeah you drank
a magnum of sake a day a magnum which is
huge if you don't know what a magnet is
it's enormous it took it his body
couldn't handle it and I did 49. he
smoked cigarettes and he drank and a
very very large amount of asake without
you know I haven't drank in over six
years but when I did I loved sake more
than anything so I'm like good choice
it's fantastic and he smoked cigarettes
but don't you think
or do you think
that that's related you don't know your
parents you're you're ripped into the
world of rinpoche ship don't you think
there's a psychological level that's
going to be like well I have a dad
shaped hole and I'm gonna fill it with
with booze without watering him down at
all
personally
that wouldn't be the way I would sum up
what I my personal experience of that
situation yeah is
um
it was and because I lived through it
and
knew him very well and kind of
experienced it firsthand there was
something unusual about him that I can't
really
you know subject to kind of putting it
into a kind of characterizable box or
something like that right right because
he he was
um
uh from my limited perspective had a
much wider access to a lot of uh looking
at the world that was beyond what I
would consider like a sort of standard
ego fixation kind of perspective
I'm sorry I never tried to copy it
and that's I think if I want to give a
message to people out there who are
looking for gurus most people aren't
these days they just need a good
spiritual friend a mentor
a guru is another category and it's very
um
much built on earlier stages of practice
and development that if those aren't
there there's there's not going to be
much role for a guru so people are like
diving into these relationships with
gurus uh I wish them good luck but
um
the guru is
is somebody who is going to take you on
a very direct path
towards recognizing
um
uh that your notion of self is is uh it
has uh a false bottom to it so they're
they're not exactly the nurturing
yoda-like person that you might wish
that you had on that kind of Journey
it's it's a dismantling
and um
so the idea of looking for security with
a guru is in my in my tradition is a
mistake
do you mean it's funny when you said
Yoda I immediately picture him hitting
Luke with that little stick so he had
like a sort of yeah but he never threw
it you know here's the here's the tell
me tell me what you meant yeah tell me
the classic definition of of a vagiana
type of Guru is they take you up in a
plane they teach you how to fly the
plane
they jump out of the plane taking the
only parachute and say good luck
this is very non-theistic it's not I'm
Gonna Save you I'm gonna nurt you I'm
gonna protect you I'll be watching over
you there's a sense of training somebody
to take care of themselves properly
and if that becomes a sycophantic
relationship it's absolutely deadly and
this just my estimation of the tradition
if you're looking for that person to
protect you to save you to um they train
you it's like being trained how did tell
I wrote down Guru because I wanted you I
don't think you ever have to tell
a trunk Pro rinpoche Story how did he
surprise you or shock you when he was
not coddling you when did he jump out of
the plane when were you like what the
[__] is this were there months where you
were like this sucks I hate this I'm I'm
depressed I'm broken or and then you had
a big breakthrough what happened the
flip side is that in order to create
that level of you know you could say
Dynamic growth in a student Dynamic
evolution
there is some kind of train uh faith
that you have confidence in that
person's achievement and that person's
uh
realization so for example you know if
you look at maharaji there are all kinds
of things where he is pulling ramdas in
to recognize the fact that um he should
trust him more at a certain level so I
did have that kind of ultimate trust but
it was tested regularly and I'm not a
faith-based person as you know I'm not a
bhakti person I'm I'm like you've got to
show me this stuff you know I'll I'll
um
and
our tradition uses critical intelligence
as the sort you know and you're
encouraged to use it so
um they were
times when I would describe it as
stretching
stretching and also
uh I could recognize that it was me that
was being stretched it was my sense of
myself that was being stretched it was
my resistance that was being stretched
it was my need to defend myself that was
being stretched and because I had
confidence in him I could I could open
up to it and learn quickly and where did
that come from what did you it's a hard
question but what did you observe in
this person it's silly but these are the
Western things was he calmed I'm glad I
think people need to evaluate this much
more seriously than it so far has
happened in the west yeah um yeah so uh
I watched him like a hawk and I watched
other great Tibetan Masters who through
his uh you know the Good Fortune of
being his student we met a lot of the
greatest Tibetan Buddhist masters of the
20th century and and saw them I watched
them and I'm not just talking about on a
stage the stage on the stage I'm talking
about when you watch them tie their
shoes
and and then some yeah and I never could
find a trace of us in increment of
defending himself of of needing to um
con anybody or stabilize how he was
perceived by somebody uh and
um also I never saw him do anything
uncompassionate and there's instances
where I saw him do
very small things that um
even towards insects and things like
that where there was obvious care for
sentient beings that was unflinchable
so I began to have um I had it
intuitively right when I met him because
I probably had previous karmas with him
you know I felt the the connection may
be similar to what you felt with ramdas
and
um and then going through certain
experiences together I found him
different than most of the people I know
in that he wasn't defensive and he was
also really creative really exploring
situation ex he was a Leading Edge
exploring the whole thing of what is it
like to bring this into the West so he
didn't cling to the you know there's
still Tibetans it's all this and so he
he manifested as a western person you
know he put on a suit he got married he
had kids uh he was not afraid to talk
about business or sex or
um you know art culture
so I I guess I found um
that his view as it was expressed was
both traditional and also very very uh
Cutting Edge and that really appealed to
me I like both I didn't want to just
pure Cutting Edge that person he has
roots that are very deep in the
tradition and then it's that you take
that to a Cutting Edge place so that's
an interesting question I don't talk
about it much with people because I
don't think they need a guru and I don't
want the thing on their Guru that's for
sure yeah so away
I love this I you did what I would do
what I loved about it was you did what I
would do and I like that you're honest
about it it's like you were watching him
like a hawk and I I do want to Circle
back and unpack it a little bit the
phenomenon that I've seen with some
teachers but not a lot I mean ramdas is
not one of those people
that ever would have claimed to be a
guru or claim that he wasn't defending
himself he would tell stories constantly
where the foothold that people like me
had to enter into the story was that he
was defending his ego or his person or
his his you know his rights his
psychological needs or whatever it might
be sure he's very human in that way but
when there are a couple that I've
listened to lectures or whatever and
they get like a q a and it's like the
most annoying question in the world and
they just don't seem they think it's
they seem to think it's funny uh does
that stir up any memory when when you
say he's not defending himself what do
you mean
hmm
not only not defending himself but there
was this again some of this was codified
into you know sort of almost like
slogans he would say your guest is as
good as mine for example you know
um but he would say don't defend
yourself and even maybe more importantly
don't defend the Dharma
oh this person's you know uh this priest
is not pure but Christianity is pure
the doctrine don't even defend the
doctrine so it's that that doesn't mean
you can't protect
the health in this situation from
obvious aggression and and con and
people who are trying to create
confusion and and hurt other people
that's a No-No but it can you know if
somebody is asking a legitimate honest
question that shouldn't threaten anybody
so like the way I teach is I say you can
ask anything you want like you just did
that you just exactly did that if I'm
sitting here going this is the open way
this is the you know the clear path
towards the crystal blah blah blah and
you asked me a question like going like
can we talk about something else that's
not so great right and that's what I
pick up from you I'm not gurifying you I
like an undefended
unsweady unclenched
person you know what I'm saying so you
you witnessed that in him like yeah I
don't mean to harp on the drinking but
if somebody was like hey why do you
drink so much would he roll with that
yeah
yeah you never experienced a taboo like
oh that that's a that's a a tough
subject
no no he he um
was pushing the envelope
uh from that point of view I would say
including the drinking had some element
of pushing the envelope
like a rascal like a no good let's well
I mean this is something that's gonna be
very hard for people to calibrate a
particularly and I don't recommend this
at all for people who are alcoholics in
some way
um which I I don't happen to be so like
and I also didn't imitate him in the
sense of like Oh I'm a student of his
now I've got to drink anybody else under
the table right but
um there is in the tantric tradition
drinking is part of it yeah he told me
that's trying to go underwater real slow
you're trying to and I don't think this
is that different from how I would use
psychedelics if I use them it's not
escapism
because it's part of your sadhna that
you're doing the Psychedelic if you're
doing drinking or psychedelic as a way
of EX you know kind of pushing the
envelope of your awareness you have to
use a lot of discipline you have to have
training so that's another thing about
him like he he seemed to be able to
navigate the space even when his body
was intoxicated his mind seemed very
very clear and Lucid it wasn't like hey
[__] all you you know I mean it was like
it felt like the same good of mine you
mean 8 P.M trunk but remember she was
the same as 8 A.M so even if his body
was acting differently yeah the mind was
very very steady yeah you're right in my
experience his mind was like a diamond
and very clear and it was almost like
you know
by many people
and that's like a highly accomplished
realized being hmm you know and are
there why Miracle Stories the clarity of
his teaching like what's going on
I'm just going to stick with the clarity
of his teaching and for people these
days just read the books and and see if
it speaks to you because we get a Dharma
Moon we get a lot of young students I
mean younger than you like in their 20s
who love drunk remember Jake and they
don't know him I mean even people twice
as old as that have never met him he's
been dead for 35 years just in case
anybody didn't notice yeah you're
talking about somebody who's been long
long gone physically but I would say the
clarity of his perspective if you read a
book like cutting through spiritual
materialism
it's so lucid and and it's such a daring
perspective of not conning people
further with oh there's this Magical
Mystery Tour you could go on and I'm the
I'm the Pied Piper of it uh it's like
you know it's wrathful it's saying let's
not let's not be fools
let's not be fools and instead
use your intelligence
to
to see what is true
and what is wishful thinking so then
well the guru thing can bring up a lot
of Wishful Thinking yeah and what what
is uncovering the truth good for
uh well the the premise would be that in
the absence of Truth we create
Fabrications that eventually unravel
anyhow
and then we have a sort of cognitive
dissonance and a lot of uh disarray and
suffering you're you're in a way you're
saving yourself from suffering you're
eating you're eating it now
you know instead of wrapping it up in
birthday paper and wrapping paper and
and postponing and unwrapping the turd
later and being really devastated
yeah yeah and and um
I mean many people have said these kind
of things that the truth is a powerful
Elixir
um and that you know like there was a
quote that just somebody posted the
other day about him he said
you know Enlightenment is profound but
so also it's self-deception in the
obstacles
are equally profound I see the spiritual
path as a very dangerous path I don't
think a lot of people see it that way
you could become a total big ass con
artist
um
you know it has the potential I've seen
it happen for people they just get
bigger than their [__] it's better to
be a rock star frankly
more honest maybe too slightly yeah I
know what you mean it's dangerous
because this is Jesus in the desert that
the devil's saying let's use this to get
famous basically like oh I see what
you're figuring out let's let's sell it
basically and that happened to Buddha
too it's called the maras
yeah daughter Samara approached and said
hey this is you know you could be this
you could have that and a lot of people
stopped there the guy when I watched the
Nexium documentary yeah I don't know if
you watch that I was like nobody moths
are drawn to light I'm not even putting
down the moths but I'm saying like
I don't care what cult it was or how
hurtful it was these are people that
listened to the Mars these are people
that listened to the Temptation that
goes let's use this to get laid or to
get rich or to get powerful or whatever
they they didn't have the
self-death that would make them
appropriate teachers what do you say you
know what the Common Thread is there
because I study this stuff I've been
doing this 50 years more than 50 years
I've watched the whole onset of uh
Eastern religion into the West just like
a scribe or an archivist I've watched
everybody I know most of the people I've
watched Zen people crap and burn I've
watched people I've watched chunker
images Dharma heirs crap and crap out
and get into very difficult and
inexplicable situations uh I I don't
hold anybody as immune from this but
here's what it seems to me at a certain
point somebody no longer has
they don't listen to their teacher
anymore
because the teacher's gone or they're or
they break away they say I'm not doing
that anymore and they don't have any
peers
hmm
so Nexium guy whatever his name is he
doesn't have a teacher and he has no
peers so nobody can tell him
hey man
check it out just let's slow this boat
down a little bit or
um I appreciate you sort of manifesting
some kind of you know Brilliance here
but uh you you're getting these women to
tattoo themselves on their inner thigh
it's not cool man right do it right not
cool it's not cool and you can't say to
them well I've passed all feedback
so at the point where somebody moves
Beyond feedback they better be very
realized right right it becomes an ego
trip and it's very tantalizing what's
more tantalizing than going like I can
solve your problems I and I have no
problems I mean what and sounds to me
like Trump trump rinbache was able to
get there and teach it without going
nuts I mean is is that a good definition
of a I I found him to be shockingly
stable
internally the mental faculty was
shocking from and you know when I met
him
he was only probably in his early 30s I
was in my early 20s he was a young man
but he had been trained from the age of
two in a very strict tradition so it's
like somebody who learned the music very
thoroughly and I found him to be
adventurous and kind we were looking for
that kind of Adventure then we weren't
looking for like a safe space we were
looking for let's bust out here so it
fit to get Gestalt of the time and then
but inside that I found him to be like
you know almost un uh
uh unnervingly stable and clear
you know and um I consider myself a
pretty good and then here's the real
kicker I could ask him anything I wanted
to
he never said don't ask I asked him
really tough stuff
I was with him in tough tough situation
well I said I said you know
some of these um
he uncovered a whole set of teachings
called Shambhala teachings which I still
think are a jewel and brilliant
I said you know is this good man is this
going to really take are people going to
be able to work with this it feels like
you know maybe it could turn into too
much form and too little substance and
instead of being insulted he just said I
really mean to do something well with
this
he just looked at like person to person
at that point it wasn't like do what I
say
so I can I encourage that with students
I say you can ask anything you can have
I'll listen to your point of view your
perspective
um hopefully we're mutually respectable
you know respectful for each other
hopefully you respect something about
experience and the depth of experience
because I think people don't value that
enough these days so look and I also say
this is my personal world you don't
don't come along it's not interesting to
you
and there's so much of it that doesn't
rely I want to have this maybe be the
final iteration
so much of the Buddhist teaching do not
rely on the guru principle
that's fajiana only
and people should be clear about it
hinian is a preceptor an elder fine the
Mahayana is a mentor a kind of spiritual
friend life coach and only if you're
practicing about Gianna's style should
you have a guru and then you should have
one so most people don't need that
they're not ready for that they're not
interested in that and you should just
say here's how to meditate go do it for
a month and then we'll talk some more
right follow your breath and we'll talk
in 30 days what about your students who
are following your path are they
I don't want to say claiming that sounds
like I'm doubting them did they say
trunk Pro rinpoche disembodied as their
Guru or are there other living gurus
that people are going for
most of what happens under the banner of
karma moon is not
uh specifically explicitly vagiana
teaching so we don't we're not using
that model we're using the model if you
can get somebody who actually knows how
to practice and has some understanding
how the mind works you can work with
them in a traditional way or if you want
a little bit of life coaching mixed in
that a one-to-one kind of thing we train
people up to a certain extent to do that
and if you do want to go study these
kind of other other implied aspects of
the of the practice
um
you know there's there's access points
but I don't want Dharma moon to become a
uh you know a lineage vehicle in that
very strict way it's very explicit
let me ask you uh this has been
wonderful I do think we can bring it in
for a landing because every time I talk
to you it's it's thick I know and we go
for it we we rolled a lot that's a lot
meaning we don't have to push to two
hours my brain is already like maybe you
should just think about that Gap thing
again
well there you go and I don't have to be
your Guru to mention it you see what I
mean yeah no exactly
well before I get to the last question I
did want to say about the Gap thing I
remember in martial arts somebody was
saying a good teacher
teaches you to notice that there are
gaps in the frame rate of reality and
that's when you're supposed to move and
that's when you're so that that's how
you can seem to like teleport or move
beside them or trip them and all this
stuff so it was interesting I know
martial arts and and spiritual
philosophy has always been in bed
together but he was saying my teacher
could wait for five people to be Mitch
McConnell for 0.05 percent of a second
and then move and seem to have jumped
four feet to the left uh it would it
just came to mind it's just a fun thing
no it's a very fun thing and here's
here's the Counterpoint
if you tune into this principle I think
you can notice
in your interaction with people
that there are these little short gaps
in their thing and and you could you
could actually see it
yeah you can see the cracks and uh
so it's not physically throwing them or
anything like that but you can engage
into that spaciousness even if it's not
very wide
you know the uncertainty the Gap is is a
great place to
allow for the conversation to expand
open up spontaneous and and it is the
essence of Comedy let's face it right
yeah I know you're looking for a way to
be able to when people Gap they laugh
yeah you Gap them yeah it's where you
can put a crowbar in and kind of open it
up a little bit more but it's also where
I'm sure
we're going back to the abuse of it like
people that figure this out but then use
it to manipulate or to coerce or yeah
it's death here's the question I have
for you and I'm I'm also kind of
prefacing it by saying this is what I
would want to ask Trump if I sat with
him I will ask you
um the same thing which is is there
anything to worry about
is there anything to worry about
so here's we can go full circle I would
say absolutely the answer is no
on the on the dunam level there's
nothing to worry about yeah
um relatively definitely
[Laughter]
you know and it's a healthy response to
a moving game you know
um
you know so I think to to understand
both of those concurrently is called the
inseparability of the two truths is very
profound and that's where I don't see
too much of it it's I think every road
leads to the inseparability of the two
truths that's that's what I would say if
you follow any path you'll get to that
point a certain point
um so yeah you should worry about
hurting people you should worry about
um deceiving yourself you should worry
about getting older and take good care
of yourself you should worry about the
health and well-being of your friends
and people that even that you don't like
um you should worry about your community
you should worry about your Society you
should worry about history you should
worry about you know the world that your
kids are going to grow up into
and then at the same time
what can you do ultimately
yeah
and at its core everything is
okay I suppose I know I'm not trying to
make this a Super Soul Sunday moment I'm
just saying like I my experience is in
the quiet of the zero
in the past no one's watching and no
one's there to watch
it's a giggle that goes what were you
even worrying about I would say the same
time
you're leaning a little towards the
absolute truth there yeah I would say
take the spice of the absolute truth and
sprinkle it into the relative truth
um
I like that like salt you know in other
words it's not wiping it out it's not
covering over a piece of meat with sauce
and you can't even taste the meat
anymore you should have a good taste of
the relative truth it's part of it's
part of it's where wisdom comes from the
relative truth has a lot to do with real
wisdom but you you have some sense of
that it's not fixed it's not permanent
uh it's not independently existing it
doesn't exist on on its own it's all
interactive and uh it doesn't really
have the kind of substance that we
attribute to it even the most precious
thing in it will shift and change and
form so
take the absolute truth and see if you
can have some time in your life where
you can relax that way at a very vast
level and then sprinkle that into your
day don't use it as a blanket but use it
as a spice I love that I needed to hear
that that's that's a lesson I need
all the time
salt
yeah Joe our editor is going to say this
guy was washed in white light he's our
video guy David thank you so much do a
little plug for Dharma Muni in case
people got the bug uh the Buddhist bug
and they want to learn some of these
practices that you've been talking about
go a little bit deeper and explore that
that quiet
um
for not just the relative truth but the
absolute truth but not just the absolute
truth the relative truth yeah so thank
you for that and you know the I would
say probably the most uh I think we'll
be airing this sometime in September and
we have there's a couple of things we
have uh Arts our sort of central program
as a color mindless meditation teacher
training program 100 hour program and
your wife Val took it which is so cool
you know that we have that connection
and um it's a five weekend program lasts
over four months and it's a really good
training it offers an initial weekend
that you can just take and see if you
like it so that maybe we could put all
that into the uh the text
with the links yeah and um that starts
October 13th before that we have an info
session for that with our friend your
friend of mine Duncan Trussell is going
to join me for an info session on that's
free that's on September 26th so if you
go to domamoon.com you will see all
these things
d-h-a-r-m-a which then um
you should buy d-a-r-m-a-moon.com
wisdom for dummies yeah you know let's
spell it w-a-s-t-u-m
um perfect yeah so yeah so go to
dharmamoon.com and maybe there'll be a
couple links in there and uh I I just
want to say that um we're not trying to
We're just trying to give people some
basic training and meditation we
actually kind of get to know what you're
doing
I I don't mean to say that other ones
are not about that but there's a Clarity
in a traditional sense of developing
mindfulness meditation as the foundation
which is a very simple practice a very
straightforward practice and it's just
learning how to be
um present with what arises in a
non-judgmental way uh opens up a lot of
space and it's for people who might want
to learn that and stabilize it but also
offer it to to other people so we're
training people how to teach so that
that's what that is hopefully we can put
the link in there and everybody will see
it and um
Pete wow man
yeah I want to give a little I want to
give a little plug I saw your act in New
York at the City Winery I was knocked
out by it man oh thank you
you know um because I've been you know
we've been sort of you know episodically
connecting at a pretty powerful level
over a number of years now and I I
thought like if you're out there people
um I mean this is Pete talking and Pete
philosophizing there's some of that in
in the ACT but there's also a kind of
energy now that I I didn't really
tap into as much where you're taking
people on a ride energetically yeah and
and we we really enjoyed it so I don't
know I'm so glad well the special this
will be out this episode's out in
September and the special will be out in
October on Netflix so it's coming around
the band yeah
here in this in this Truth uh we're
editing it tomorrow
but in the reality that this air is it's
almost out so I'm glad right well what
what uh what's the name of it it's
called I am not for everyone
huh
there you go well I pity the fool that
you're not poor I know but if you
remember it's a line in the ACT uh I am
not for everyone
um I also you're a marketing guy you
have that wonderful book creativity
spirituality and making a buck so in the
marketing of it it's not to coerce
people I feel like my fans will watch it
but people who don't know who I am
it's itchy like why is this guy saying
I'm not for everyone as opposed to like
sunshine potato chips time who [__]
cares a guy that says this isn't for
everybody it makes you go like it's the
Pepsi challenge which one's Coke like
it's it's it's individualized are you
from me am I for you it makes it more
indeed yeah they do it the market like
they'll have somebody in a in a bar
who's on the marketing team and they're
just supposed to talk to the person next
and say I'm into this thing you know
it's just for the person next to you yep
that's right and and what's up well very
cool and you know while you're
mentioning that I think you and I are
both on the same track which has brought
us sort of strongly together of being
creative people everybody knows I'm a
musician and a composer and I you know
produce
Krishna dots records and play guitar for
all kinds of people and Etc but I've
always wanted to weave those three
things together creativity spirituality
and making a buck so if you don't come
to any of our trainings or classes or
anything like that uh check out the book
check out the books yeah and um I think
it's in sync with the kind of
conversations we have are always weaving
their way through those topics and
you've always well you I'm happy to say
I know you know I love you and you know
I don't have to it's not news to you
which is wonderful because people should
know uh in fact I had an English teacher
that said you should say you love me
like like tell people you love me like
that's better than saying I love you
it's going like I can tell you love me
and I can tell you love me but like I've
I've turned to you all always in the
spiritual thing going like
what is this you know we're having these
conversations and last night I was
screaming about diarrhea and and like
it's wonderful to just go like it's all
holding hands and it's all together and
that's so refreshing from you know the
type of spirituality I was raised in was
all about being polite and nice and
decent and wear a suit and have a
haircut and I'm like [__] that [__]
wow I do want to say Melanie is one of
my absolute favorites and also Melania
is not a clean comic so what my dad
thinks John Mulaney is John Mulaney is
not and I have nothing but love for John
I think everybody knows that I'm just
saying yeah we're I'm not going for the
um the polite thing
yeah it's um there's something Prismatic
in the whole thing Pete that's really
like if you can see the whole picture of
your dad John Mulaney you me Leela
Val ramdas there's some World in which
that's all a big giant prism of
interactivity and it is beautiful I
agree I agree stunning actually before
you said it I was like that is so funny
you just gave me like an outside of
myself perspective hearing all those
names and thinking my play in that I'm
like this really is pretty funny
all of it and pretty beautiful but thank
you for reminding us we never are we
ready to start the recording the podcast
now we never we never had a beginning
I welcomed you
I said welcome started talking yeah
sorry buddy it's all going live like the
old Jewish guy just wandered onto the
set you know that's it that's all we
needed and you were ready to go well if
you remember we end the show with you
saying keep it crispy if you this is
your second time on so you you this is
your second keep it crispy would you say
keep it crispy and then we'll be done
here
I would say keep on keeping it crispy
everybody
keep on keeping it crispy assuming they
already have been keeping it crispy I
like that I'm assuming they have had
some introduction now
you're in the middle of the middle of
the marathon you're getting a little
tired keep on keeping it crispy yeah
you're in maintenance
keep it great thank you David
[Music]